is a fun calculation you do in
astrophysics graduate school and I know
the word fun and calculation are not
always in the same sentence
what you do is you ask yourself suppose
the gravitational constant if it was
slightly different
what effect would it have on for example
the Luminosity of the sun yeah when you
do that calculation you find that the
Luminosity of the sun depends to the
seventh power
on the gravitational constant damn
so if the gravitational constant was was
a tiny bit higher
than the Luminosity of the sun would be
unacceptably high for anything we enjoy
and love here on Earth in our Goldilocks
zone so it's not that everything is in
delicate balance don't think about it in
those terms it's that we are what works
with the properties that exist in this
unit